dans l'art de manier les cerceaux et des
balles la concentration et de rigueur
une règle avec laquelle le directeur du
cirque clown de métier ne plaisante pas
les spas ton bras en l'air comme ça tu
laisses tu descends of silence je
récupère laisse bien tes mains en bas le
jonglage une des nombreuses disciplines
artistiques l'école de cirque du pôle en
scène depuis la rentrée à des enfants de
tous les âges et de tous horizons
nolan nuit souffre d'un trouble du
comportement hyperactif ses cours de
cirque vous permettent de canaliser son
énergie
il attend chaque mercredi avec
impatience attendu ce qui est promis
d'aller au cirque on a déjà ne plus
faire n'importe qui raillent les effets
du du cirque le cirque a également
changé d'avis dana à 16 ans
l'adolescente rêve déjà d'une carrière
professionnelle
depuis que j'ai perdu mon papa tout le
monde pense que je suis faible alors qu
en fait pas du tout derrière ma carapace
que je suis de 6000 tri ce que je peux
être plus remuant du caractère pour la
vache quelqu'un qui n'a pas du tout
confiance en moi et avec tout ça le
siècle et festivals ça m'a redonné
confiance si je me sens beaucoup mieux
qu'avant pour sa maman c'est aussi
l'occasion de voir anna s'ouvrir aux
autres
c'est quand même plus intéressant de la
voir évoluer d'ailleurs avec des jeunes
là aujourd'hui que plutôt d'être
derrière un ordinateur un écran ou
quelque chose quoi un seul et puis c'est
vraiment une passion qu'elle a donc
choquel la vie va t'on des cours compris
entre 180 et 300 euros par an et qui ne
sont pas seulement réservé aux meilleurs
éléments qu'on n'est pas forcément bon
en tout il ya des jeunes qui sont très
bons à la jonglerie est très mauvais aux
trapèzes et la verse et je trouve ça
très intéressant de respecter aussi la
différence de niveau et ça fait du sens
du respect que simplement il souhaite
une belle valeur à à mettre en avant au
sein du cirque en tout cas sous le
chapiteau de beaune la rolande la relève
semble déjà assurée